oops
good evening members and officers
welcome to this meeting of the executive
13th of June 2022.
can I first of all take apologies for
absence I've received from councilor
Danielle Belton who has a another
engagement she couldn't miss this
evening other than that looking around
the room I think everyone is here so no
other apologies
Belton
moving on to item two
despite chairs out for an assembly hall
there aren't any other members of the
public here but there are there is
one non-member of the executive
attending and a warm welcome to
councilor
Stuart Wilson
welcome thank you and we'll be hearing
from you later no doubt councilor Wilson
moving on to item three minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of March 2022
they have been circulated and in some
agenda packs they're included
um
so uh members are you consent for me to
sign those minutes do you agree them for
me to sign agreed
thank you very much
agenda item four to receive Declarations
of interest on any items on the agenda
any declarations to be made
nope
moving on to
item five questions on notice from
counselors and none have been received
which takes us nicely on to matters
referred to the executive reports from
other committees and there are none so
we're making good progress with this
agenda
um
item seven
the economic growth strategy 2022-2025
and the way I'm going to play this
councilor Ward
um if you can just very briefly
introduce it and I'm sure you will hand
over to uh I beg your pardon Council
award it's councilor Belton um who is
missing that's yes my brain is running
slow tonight uh you looked a little bit
surprised there
um but uh
um but your turn will come in a moment
for the for the last item um but I will
refer to Mr hotton to take us through
the economic growth strategy Please Mr
hot
thank you good evening members the
economic growth strategy before you this
evening sets out the key themes
priorities and objectives
that as a council we aspire to deliver
it replaces the last such strategy from
2017. and it's based on three main
themes supporting local business growth
attracting new investment and improving
the skills base of residents
and these seem to provide a set of
deliverable objectives for the next
three years that reflect the council's
current Ambitions and the draft strategy
as such is appended to the reports this
was taken through overview in scrutiny
and you'll see that you've gone addendum
that supports this original reports that
councilor Wilson will then be able to
take you through now thank you
questions from members
councilor FD
no I
will have a question about like Council
Wilson take you through first okay all
right lovely so none on the uh outline
put forward to us by Mr hotman
um at that point as I said a little
earlier a warm welcome thank you for
giving up your evening to come and join
us uh Stuart really appreciate that
um I attended the overview and scrutiny
committee meeting last week along with
the deputy leader and I have to say I
thought that it was extremely
constructive uh I do like this idea of
putting through these reports that we
hear at executive but it feels that a
job is being properly done in the sense
that they're being scrutinized and then
we listen to uh the outcome of that uh
scrutiny process and we consider the
recommendations and move it from there
so
um if you've got any comments to make to
us I believe you have
yes thank you chairman
um the what I'd say first of all is that
there was a positive response from
members of the overview and scrutiny
committee to this report the
um
if I go through the recommendations if
that's okay with you the the first
recommendation uh paragraph 1.2 which
relates to paragraph 6.1 of the report
and this is about changing
um the relative figures for the budgets
I spoke to Mr hotton about this before
we had the meeting and and the figures
in the budget are clearly indicative and
I think what members of the of my
committee were trying to get across was
that perhaps we should be spending Less
on the promotion materials and more on
training
um and more and earmarking more for
emerging projects as well so members of
my committee were hoping that we'd be
quite ambitious with this program
you want me to move on to the next uh
any questions at that point
counselor FD well this this was going to
be my question
um where we've cut five thousand pound
off the ten thousand pound budget for
promotion materials and branding now
over the last couple of years
um I've had complaints that we don't
seem to have a presence in Watford with
branding
um is this gonna
damage our
presence in what should with our
branding we won't have another or have
half what we're supposed to have for any
and still get complaints about
what does what should council do
I'll take that as a if we can just hold
the reply there
um but uh Council award did you very
much chairman it was in a similar vein
actually I believe we've got a
considerable mount in reserve on that
budget I think because it's an extra
thirty thousand is act
um I I do really I'm listening to
councilors after these concerns with
regard to marketing and I do think it's
important and maybe we should be leaving
that but giving the extra to the skills
and training rather than moving that
around is that possible to do that we'll
hold up one as well thank you we may
Council of weapon
thank you chairman I was going to make
the same point as councilor Warden
Council FD five thousand pounds feels
like a very modest sum of money and
we've got to remember this we'll
probably be covering at least three town
centers I'd imagine what should Hockley
and Riley
um I don't think five thousand pounds is
adequate for that piece of work no issue
with increasing the amount for the
skills and trainings ten thousand pounds
but I would certainly be more
comfortable if the budget for for
Branding and promotion was ten thousand
pounds still
thank you counselor Webb any other
comments before I make mine
I think we've all picked up on that
particular Point
um when I first read this before it went
to scrutiny
um I have to say I don't like such round
figures in the sense I appreciate that
they're indicative
but to be asking to sign off on
particular lines where we don't know the
actual amounts doesn't sit comfortably
with me and I think overview and
scrutiny took it to a further level of
trying to play around with round amounts
but not actually having an informed
position on exactly how much each line
might be I understand the spirit in
which they were trying to do that but I
don't think it's a particularly a
sensible thing to try and start
guesstimating what we might need in
terms of bands and so I'm quite uneasy
at accepting that recommendation
personally because
I'd like to see more precise Figures
it's not because I'm in any way
disagreeing with overview and scrutiny I
think the spirit was well intended I
think I'd like to see some more accurate
figures so just to say well let's not
5000 off here and we'll add it somewhere
else just seems a little random to me
and I'd like to see a more informed view
personally before we accept that
recommendation Nation so with those four
comments I think pretty similar in vain
will pass over to Mr hotton to give a
reply we decide whether we're going to
go with that recommendation if we make
thank you so so I think the um the
budgets were merely indicative I mean it
wasn't
um the original report didn't allude to
a decision on those as such but it's
more for information so uh in terms of
um I think I was raised by a view and
scrutiny we I can understand there was a
concern how that could reflect
um priorities I think they were in
substancing that as a priority that
should be given to training over sort of
marketing but I think
uh the there is a ample budget to to
address the priorities of both I think
within reserves is required it was just
merely indicative of how the spend could
be um delivered over that year but it
isn't something that was a decision
before that evening or really something
we anticipate too much discussion around
thank you
thank you uh councilor Wilson do you
want to come back on on that
I think it's a fair discussion there's a
fair points you've made I was myself a
little bit uneasy about putting specific
figures down I'll throw an edge of the
conversation with Mr hot and so it's
really
I think if I can sort of paraphrase what
other Council have said if we can spend
more on training than it than is
indicated
I think that's the I haven't got a
figure in mind but I just think that
would be
do you know Council Wilson I don't think
there's any difference between this
actually we're all saying the same thing
but I think what we're saying is those
are fair headings but to start putting
an actual figure to them without
actually having a more precise rationale
for how we arrive at that we understand
actually the spirit and actually agree
with the spirit but to start putting
figures it looks as if well we've
allowed thirty thousand so let's see how
we can just split it around I think the
executives would be the executive view
would be we want to get the job done
properly under all those headings yeah
and whatever is the appropriate cost
um so I don't think that actually
affects the overall recommendation of
the report but the message I believe
from the executive
um and I think it dovetails into
overview and scrutiny is whatever it
costs to get the job done properly
mindful of the comments made at overview
and scrutiny which I thought were very
helpful but also not constraining to
those
is that approach acceptable
thank you thank you members
right
um I don't think 1.3 to 1.8 might be
quite so difficult but uh take us
through them please
um so
um within within the report
um there were no clear Smart kpis in
there and again in discussion with Mr
Hopton this is a strategy so you
wouldn't expect lots and lots of detail
in there the only thing I would say is
that you would expect perhaps high level
kpis at this stage so we know where
we're where we're heading
any questions or comments on that
Council award
on performance
but I think this was such a high level
view I think as you start moving forward
and you move into it I think you've got
to have the performance indicators
coming forward so I mean you you've
highlighted that but I think it probably
didn't come out in this report I think
it's indicated in this report but it
doesn't jump out at you
maybe that's a fault
thank you Council award Council ft
again no problem with the kpis it's just
I'm I was at the viewing scrutiny
committee as well and I think there was
a question there was a point made that
went what
when they get reported back what sort of
time scale
really in time scale maybe six months
and three months or three months to
overview and scrutiny
that might be something that can be
answered
Mr Hutton do you wish to reply thank you
I'm pretty good to dance because
um and Daniel couldn't hear just to
comment on the on the times going I
think traditionally um there's an
implementation plan that underpins the
strategy
um and you'd find that the kpis would be
um within that but I think it's the time
scale of the implementation plan one
that we brought forward that Daniel
should be assault
well thank you yes so I mean
traditionally we've produced separate
implementation plans and they tend to be
less formal documents not not public so
much and they would tend to contain kpis
so I think what would be very happy to
do is make the implementation plan
essentially the the reporting document
that came back
um so I mean I'm fairly comfortable with
agreeing to call almost kind of
quarterly probably reporting on the
performance understanding some months
there might be some quarters there may
be less to report
um I think we can easily give an
indication of of kpis I think they'll be
fairly standard around business growth
number of businesses uh key key kind of
infrastructure projects that have been
completed in that in that window but I
think in a sense the objectives were
included to indicate the types of things
that will be focused on and the kpis
would probably be subject to separate
reporting
um that's traditionally how how we've
dealt with it
councilor Ward yeah I'm just making an
assumption here now I guess that as the
plan progresses you will then be able to
measure how well it is progressing and
the work that is being done on it so I
think that's probably a fairer way of of
understanding
how this will actually develop again
high level once you start getting in
place what you want to do and how you're
doing it then you can measure oh you're
doing it are you doing it on time has it
been done to your satisfaction
um Council Ward I think that's
absolutely right but to summarize on
that point if I may uh I think it was
quite clear and and if I'm reading the
message correctly is about having a
clear understanding of outcomes uh what
the time frame is for those outcomes and
the reporting mechanism councilor Wilson
I don't want to put words into your
commitment are you happy yes thank you
because I'd like that recorded that
there's there's some definitive
reporting lines we all understand what
the outcome is and by what time so that
we can actually use some sort of rag
analysis to see we're on Target off
Target or whatever yeah and if I could
just add chair that um I spoke to
councilor Belton at the meeting and this
is exactly what she wants to take
forward yeah lovely all right good
because I'm just free conscious that I
don't then start twisting what so as
long as you're happy as as chairman
um and we move on then to 1.4
Yep this is
um this is about keeping it local where
we can trying to do stuff within our own
economy if we are grown it if we're
trying to grow our economy then we
should be using the resources within our
economy
um rather than going outside of it so
it's really
um to try to look whether we can use
local businesses more um and including
Local Schools as well perhaps with some
of the media work
um I I this is actually a point that
councilor Sperry made to me and I'm just
wondering if it has any any bearing
where I'd say people apply for a job and
I know this if we're our company has
applied for for large jobs large things
to do but we can't get in because there
are so many different requirements now
I'm wondering if the smaller companies
do struggle with actually getting an
opportunity because the requirements
that are put in there they just can't
meet even though they would be really
good they would be ideal but it's just
the way that the forms are set out
that become quite difficult for a small
company to actually put in a bid and
feel confident in putting in that bid
even though they could do the job I am I
getting that across
actually I agree running a small
business I agree with that 100 very
often we don't bother to Tender for any
large public bodies it's just too
difficult
um but what I would say is that what
we're not suggesting is that we go
against procurement regulations so it's
it's I fully
and the way that they're set out I know
that a lot of the forms were down to
Europe if I may say chairman I wonder
now we're out of Union out of Europe is
there an opportunity to actually change
the way that we actually construct those
forms and I I think what we're probably
all agreed on and again I don't want to
put words in is that the forms are
user-friendly to appeal to or to to
ensure that all businesses are able
including our local businesses it's not
restricting it just to corporates but I
sort of feel that as the chief executive
has drawn his microphone towards him he
may want to give us some guidance
thank you chairman just wanted to pick
up the levels of values we're putting in
this proposal uh very much below what
we'd normally go out for a full
procurement exercise so we'd look for a
number of proposals and quotes so we're
not looking at a full-blown procurement
process for these types of values
obviously we go for the proper
procurement methods and process has been
agreed by the council but we wouldn't
expect a small business or a large
business for the value of ten thousand
pounds of being in a full tender
requirement there will be a process but
hopefully not to owners for any local
business
in that case thanks for that
clarification I think that really sums
up the fact that we want to make this
very appealing to local businesses
um and uh
Council of waterpoint then to actually
get that across we want to invite local
businesses
to be able
to come in and and not be afraid to bid
I think we've got the uh message Council
award
um you know we want to in the first
instance attract be attractive to to
local businesses
thank you and that's no just just for
Comfort I'm thinking of recollecting of
the um
um sort of marketing uh and Printing and
Design that we've done for the economic
development sort of work so far has all
been um sort of in the district so it's
you know I think that's that's already
happening as
um the Civics is already alluded to you
know the term the amounts that we're
dealing with are prohibitive I think for
for basically three quotes there isn't
too much of a uh too much onerous uh
bidding to go on at this level thank you
okay thanks for that clarification
moving on to 1.5
this was to do with um within the report
itself it mentions Roxford local and
there was some concerns with members
that we should also use Google business
as well because it's got a wider reach
on it rather than just look within the
Rochford area so it's a fairly
I would say straightforward
recommendation hopefully
well I think it's straightforward but I
will put it over to members to see
whether they agree everyone agreed
any further come in
nope okay agreed
okay
1.6 yeah
um and and this is really to try and
Achieve economies of scale working
within uh Brentford Borough Council to
see uh whether we can share resources on
this and what lessons we can share with
each other
well it's
what we want to do
um and I think the point was made in the
meeting that there is a perception
rightly or wrongly that Brentwood may be
a little bit further ahead with this
sort of stuff than we are and certainly
we're in a position hopefully to benefit
from their knowledge and expertise but
we'll agree to that
good okay
um 1.7 Council Wilson yeah this is a
perhaps a bit more contentious and I
would say this wasn't unanimously agreed
at the meeting which was to change the
wording from Fantastic connections to
develop fantastic connections and I know
that Mr hotton probably thinks that
we're underselling ourselves so
you didn't want that recommendation I
don't think I'd be too upset
yeah
um members any comments
Mr hotton
sorry mate having to drive through uh
sort of a Lee at the weekend we've got
excellent infrastructure compared to
other areas I think we just forget that
so it's uh I think uh it would be a
shame to undersell ourselves I think
it's relative I think we tend to give
ourselves a hard time but actually our
infrastructure connections are are of a
good standard so I think it's you know
if you're going to sell yourself you've
got to put a good foot forward rather
than keep making apologies so fantastic
infrastructure in my opinion ought to
stay thank you
Council of Webb help me out thank you
chairman just reading this paragraph
um it currently says with fantastic
fantastic connections to key employment
markets in Basildon Park and south of
Don Sea by Road and rail if it was
changed to read to encourage the
development of fantastic connections to
baselton South and unsea it will become
a bit of a nonsense because we've
already got fantastic connections to
those areas we've got rail links we've
got Road Links we've got an airport and
our doorstep I'm not quite sure whoever
came up with one point
seven I'm not quite sure what they
envisaged people done to further those
connections so it seems a bit of a
non-starter that's why I'm not concerned
I I think it the word fantastic is quite
a strong word isn't it when um we hear
from residents connectivity and driving
to some of these places isn't quite as
fantastic as the word it says implies
and I think that was the sort of spirit
behind the comment but councilor ft
helped me out
is absolutely fantastic so
go go with it yeah
cancer Wilson no I'm as I say it wasn't
voted on unanimously
um and I I don't like to sell the
district show either so
I I certainly don't want to do anything
that suggests sending a short so sorry
Chief exactly is that okay to come in
thank you just um I think it's about
audiences this document's organic
development strategy one of the key
audience will be in from an investment
and sort of inspire people to come to
Roxford to invest
um I think you need to be as bold and
with our outcomes if you say okay or
words like that fantastic connection
would hopefully entice people rather
than say we're getting there or it's
coming soon so I think we need to be
really bold and we have got great
connections again it's relative to the
place locally on a level of everybody
probably in the country feels they
haven't got the right infrastructure so
I think we'd be with them but we have
got fantastic we've got the only airport
in Essex or South Essex
um in our on our patch so we should be
talking about that we've got rail
connections into Friendship Street and
Liverpool Street really good connections
as well it doesn't mean we can be
complacent but I would say we should be
really bold and say say we have got
fantastic connections um for the
audience that's going to see this
document
calculus bearing
I would agree with the comments have
been made chairman they it implies that
we're playing catch-up again and I think
on there are some things that we are
ahead of the game on and and this is one
of them and uh I I agree it gives out a
negative View
and we don't need to start trying to
justify where we are and
thank you councilman sparing councilor
Williams
thank you chairman um I don't like the
word fantastic particularly but where it
has encouraged the development of
fantastic connections can we not have to
continue
to encourage development we've done it
anyway so
we're continuing
just a thought
Council Ward
well
the way I would read it and enhance it
would be enhanced by our membership of a
sailor because that's exactly what it
would do because I would read it
Rochford forms part of the South South
Essex economy with fantastic connections
to key employment markets in Basildon
thurrock and South Bend on Sea by both
Road and rail enhanced by our membership
of a joint membership of a sailor which
brings it all together I would have
liked to have seen a sailor in here well
I think that's a really good point
because it's proving that we can't do
this all on our own working with with
partners
I you know I'm with councilor Williams
um in terms of the word fantastic which
we've got used in this era to using some
very strong words
um but then I think the GP Tech makes a
really good point but you've got to be
mindful of the audience that this is
projected towards and um we can't sell
ourselves shortly we actually need to
play it up uh so um with that in mind
um councilor Wilson what do you want us
to do because these are your
recommendations
thanks chairman I'd I'd like to go along
with Council Awards recommendation about
putting a seller in there as well
um notwithstanding the word fantastic
um
I'm not sure of a better world I mean is
it is a strong word isn't it and we
shouldn't be selling ourselves sure
and and you know when you look at it we
I do think we take ourselves for granted
yeah help me again please Council
believe in ourselves why should anybody
else absolutely
okay so it was a fantastic place
so I'm I'm feeling the consensus
councilor Williams
a bit like Harry Potter isn't it you
know fantastic and and you know that
sometimes it's overrated that word
I'm not sure about that but fine and do
you know Council Williams I'm sort of
with you but I don't want to sell a
short
um but I understand perhaps we live in
an era where uh fantastic really was
fantastic but now these words are used
more commonly
um and perhaps we need to move into the
new era Council Williams you and I
perhaps it's an age thing
so on the basis that we don't seem to be
able to do any better we're going to
leave it as it is but add in a seller is
that all agreed is that fair enough yes
lovely
um
1.8 Council Wilson Yep this was um came
up from a number of members who were
aware of schemes at other local
authorities had undertaken and it was to
be a
ambitious with with what we're doing and
to look at other areas and as I
understand it
um Chelmsford city council have got some
good schemes going on about regenerating
the High Street and it's just a
suggestion to look at that scheme to see
whether we can learn any lessons and
whether we can bring any thing to bear
in The District
yes
um
Mr hotton oh sorry members before we
moved to Mr hot
councilor FD
don't want to limit it to Charleston
City Council and I says EG's Chelsea
city council but we should be looking at
all councils who are doing a really good
job of regenerating our house their High
streets and see what we can learn
thank you councilor Hefty any other
member comments before I pass across
no I was in radio High Street this
weekend I think Chelmsford could
probably take a lesson from how we do
things in Rayleigh it was absolutely
brilliant and congratulations as an
aside to everyone involved with Trinity
Fair uh I thought it was fantastic and
I'm using it in the uh sense that I mean
it to actually for us to be out there in
that sort of High Street I thought it
was brilliant fantastic extraordinary
and any other strong word that I can
find in the English dictionary
um so I do agree with you councilor FD I
think EG is appropriate because it is
one area but I think we should be open
to exploring any other town we should
actually be looking at Partners
sometimes it could be a more run
downtown that has actually got a
ambitious plan that we think we could
buy into but again I don't want to sell
ourselves short when you look around the
Rochford district from wakering in the
East through to Rayleigh in the west we
have got some fantastic parades of shops
we've got some fantastic
sub-centers uh in the form of Rochford
Hockley
um and um you know we should be very
proud of that but that doesn't mean to
say we should be so smug that we don't
actually take lessons from others I did
when I was sitting in the audience I did
think to myself well why are we honing
on on Chelmsford because everything is
wonderful about Chelmsford they have a
few issues and they haven't found the
solutions to that but I certainly take
the spirit that we're open so I would
say EG Chelmsford
um and and other places but
there we are Mr Holton did you wish to
add anything to that
um only that I mean I think it's it's a
given that you're always trying to share
best practices across different sort of
economic groups you know um so I mean
the Essex officers do meet regularly to
discuss best practices across Essex and
would then also discuss case studies
further afield so I think it's almost a
given but I'm happy for to be taking as
a recommendation thank you
lovely thanks that takes us to the end
of the recommendations a bit of
discussion around that Council Wilson
did you wish to add anything before we
moved to uh no thank you chairman right
okay
um now clearly we can't embrace all of
that within the recommendations of the
report but certainly there is a clear
agreement and and value that uh overview
of scrutiny have put on this report
really appreciate that but you can feed
that back to your committee
um but uh if you're happy members unless
there's any further comments we'll move
to the recommendations uh set out
Germany if I'm
if I meant just just for a um overview
as to what has been discussed or members
are clear
um in addition to the recommendations
under paragraph one there appears to be
a recommendation one uh decision uh
additional uh decision 1.3 to agree the
following recommendations of overview
and scrutiny so to be clear
um on the addendum 1.2 is not accepted
yeah because uh 6.1 refers to
anticipated costs
and um
and it's been drawn down from balance of
63 000. so paragraph 1.2 a sorry is not
accepted B and CR
and the 10 000 to hold business Network
and other events remains as well that's
already in the report
1.3 for there to be clear and smart
measurable kpis accepted and as Mr
Goodman has explained this will be
separate implementation plans
and with time scales yes uh 1.4 is
accepted at the procurement of local
schools and businesses 1.5 is accepted
with regards to encouraging business to
use Google business
1.6 working with Brentwood Borough
Council to develop skills is accepted
1.7 is not however members have agreed
additional wording to
page 7.7
um I would suggest that in the last on
page 7.7 way it says
I know there was a lot of discussion
around fantastic connections so where
the sentence starts our region is also a
key growth area
perhaps you could say our region is that
also Keith Grove growth area for the
government supported by large investment
in the Thames Freeport and lower terms
Crossing and our membership offers
seller add those words at the end of
this
and keep what we've got about the
Fantastic connections
I would like to see our seller spelled
out as
Association of South Essex local
authorities with a seller in Brackets
because I think we add that to the end
of the paragraph is that agreed members
yeah
chairman
um Ms law has mentioned 1.2 where we've
talked about uh section A not being
agreed but B and C were
I thought with the understanding was
that we would make sure that we had the
money available to do the job properly
well I was going to come back on on 1.2
but I thought we'd just worked through
to the end
um and then still come back to 1.2
um because I too am still uneasy about
that
um but let's bring in councilor Ward
we want to see greater Clarity in Our
intention Our intention is to actually
be flexible in its use to get best out
of what we need where we need it and
however we need it well in French to the
monitoring officer so 1.7
you've suggested some wording we've
we've
yes to
a paragraph our region is also a key key
growth area for the government supported
by large investment in the Thames for
reports and lower Thames Crossing and
our membership of a seller but the full
title of a seller no
well if it doesn't work for you Council
Ward the only sees on you to come up
with something that works for you and
see whether it work for the rest of us
um immediately after the south end on
sea both Road and area enhanced
enhanced by our membership of a sailor
it directly refers then back to that
fantastic connection that is being made
because then if you drop down you've
lost the point
I'm glad I've got some good legal
advisors near me tonight
if I if I may just comment I think the
sentence
um
relates to connections by Road and Rail
and not the membership of a seller
whereas of course the investment piece
that is referred to as Freeport and low
attempts Crossing is directly linked to
the membership of a seller that's why
the suggestion was that we should
mention a seller in the latter sentence
not the former
and at that point I'd like to bring Mr
Hutton back in because he may
thank you and just uh if I can um bring
you back to the original report
um and the decision 1.2 obviously is
about sort of uh the idea of a necessary
minor amendments which is which is
changing to census instructors like um
is to be delegated down to myself and
the portfolio holder for clothing
economy so I think what we can do is
take this away and we're happily
um discuss that with councilor Belton
but um through Council Bill to
yourselves as well that these sort of
changes just just consciously it's
becoming a a discussion about about
precise sentences and wording but that
can be done I think outside of this this
um executive I would suggest if people
are consent to do so
right I'm just getting a little confused
now about what point we are talking what
so one point we're talking about
yeah Council vote I think
Marcus I think you've moved on to back
to 1.2 1.2 of the recommendations we are
actually still discussing on point two
of the
um over overview of scrutiny if I may
what I'm saying is I think you can pick
those up through the original
recommendation that some of these minor
changes and changes to wording could be
we could be dealt with outside of this
this meeting
right I just want to come back to the
monitoring officer on 1.7 of the
addendum that's what I'd like to try and
agree first yeah
chairman
there has been suggestion by Council
Ward and the suggestion by Miss Hutchins
which would you like to go for
a combination of the two
um
I think chairman I think we agreed that
um with chairman of the overview in
scrutiny
um
um we can probably outside of this
meeting we I mean we all agree that we
need to add the words of seller in there
somehow allow membership so we perhaps
can come up with some wording outside of
the um
um meeting
um in consultation with the portfolio
holder I I think that seems to be a
sensible Way Forward doesn't it
otherwise we need you with something but
it does need to be so so 1.7 can read uh
that reference to a seller be included
on page 7.7 of the report
so it so it's noted that the decision
has been made so I will come up with
some wording
that member's happy with happy with that
Council Wilson
okay all right
um sorry Council vote can we then just
make sure that you as leaders are happy
with that as well
and then 1.8 is agreed
right
so so chairman come back to 1.2 I think
the point sorry just before we move so I
have ticks against
one point uh well I've got ticks against
1.3 1.4 1.5 1.6
1.7 you're still subject to that will
read um that reference to a seller be be
included on page 7.7 of the report but
there will be wording agreed outside of
this meeting uh 1.8 is agreed yeah at
1.2 I have to say from my point of view
in the light of the feedback from
overview and scrutiny and
the comments passed here I think there
is unease at the
the figures being applied to the
breakdown the breakdown is agreed
but I'm not sure the figures
and and I think from if I'm reading it
correctly the executive agree with
overview and scrutiny about
the figures not actually tying up but
to just plot figures out of the sky and
that's not being disingenuous to the
writer of the report but
it would be better to leave those
headings in there but took about an over
uh overall figure of 30 000 pounds
um with the detail but I'm not quite
sure how that can be wrapped up within
the recommendation of the report so so
chairman that that can be done so it's
and we can say that on paragraph 6.1 the
report is noted that the appropriate
sums
be spent as agreed with the portfolio
holder for climate and economy I think
it it needs um members I mean the the
balance there is a balance of circus 63
000 and it is as uh Miss Tartan and Mr
Goodman said is uh anticipated amount
that to spend but they cannot as you say
put a definitive figure on it but the
headlines are there you know money will
be used towards uh to improve place and
promotion materials and branding to
whole business networking events to
invest in skills and training including
schools careers program and a
contingency to address projects that
emerge throughout the year I think that
the the important figure is that there
is a a budget of 63
000 for this
um for this spend okay
um
so subject to all of that because
actually we are at one with agreeing
actually we're just having a continuing
discussion
um really on from overview on scrutiny
uh about those figures but uh the key
thing is the first part of 6.1 that
paragraph with the headings rather than
putting figures to those headings yes um
the I mean the portfolio holder would
have it's it would be within her remit
to spend that money as it's uh already
reserved okay
um so with that all in mind can we now
turn to the recommendations at 1.1 and
1.2 or do you want us to get agreement
on uh 1.61 through to 1.8 so Jim and
there'll be an additional recommendation
or additional decision being made that a
1.3 that it's agreed that the following
recommendations
um of ovary and scrutiny as we have just
discussed is agreed okay all right so I
think we're there if everyone agrees uh
so at 1.1 that the draft Economic
Development strategy be approved as set
out in the appendix is that agreed
1.2 that delegated authority be given to
the assistant director placing
environment in consultation with the
portfolio holder climate and economy to
make any necessary minor amendments to
the draft Economic Development strategy
in advance of publication
agreed
and a further recommendation of 1.3 that
the recommendations from the overview
and scrutiny committee are supported
subject to the further discussion that
we've had I chairman I will list
the
recommendations being 1.2
being on paragraph 6.1 of the report is
noted that the appropriate sums are
within the 63
000
be spent on agreed as agreed with the
portfolio holder 1.3 Remains the Same
1.4 Remains the Same 1.5 Remains the
Same 1.63 Remains the Same 1.7 that
reference to a seller be included in on
page 7.7 of the report and 1.8 Remains
the Same so that will be listed in the
final decision thank you very much to
the monitoring officer for guiding us
through that very effectively is that
all agreed members
thank you
and thank you councilor Wilson you're
most welcome to stay for our next item
or if you wish to take your leave we we
understand
it's only that I've got a very nice
Curry that was cooked and everyone that
I've eaten it by the time I get home
thank you chairman so so now councilor
Wilson everyone on the tape now knows
that you've got Curry tonight
thank you enjoy right thank you very
much indeed for for attending tonight
really appreciate that
right members moving on to item eight
um I was a bit enthusiastic Council
award uh to pull you in earlier but uh
um I now is your big moment actually to
introduce this report thank you very
much indeed chairman
um well the decision being recommended
is at the local plan transport
assessment be commissioned using an
allocation of up to two hundred thousand
pounds from a dedicated ldf Reserve
basically
we will need to have a transport
assessment for this District so we're
able to understand our future planning
and if we don't have it
we will not know realistically whether
we are making the right choices
as far as
the places we wish to put our jobs
and our homes
and other things around the district
because they have to be connected and we
have to understand those connections and
this is probably in my opinion the most
important evidential document that we're
going to need going forward
I'd like to hand that over now to either
Marcus
or Daniel who have been working very
very hard to bring this you know bring
this forward
Jim Council thank you very much indeed
which one of you is going to thank you
um yes so just so that members have a
bit of an understanding so we're
obviously progressing with the the local
plan we're looking to arrive at a kind
of preferred option stage later this
year so it's quite a critical phase now
in terms of making decisions about
future strategy uh obviously over a
fairly long period of time so the
purpose of a local plan transport
assessment really is to take a
model-based approach to looking at the
impacts of further growth in the
district over a 20 to 30 year period so
by model lead assessment what I what I
really mean is that using data from kind
of observed traffic and Junction wait
times and other data such as that being
able to draw real and realistic
conclusions about the impacts of future
development on those uh Junctions and
roads but also being able to look at the
mitigation that might be needed in the
long term to make those impacts
acceptable
and so it is a technical assessment it
will take probably the best part of 12
to 18 months to complete in full but it
will be a multi-stage assessment so it
will provide useful outputs to guide
decision making throughout
um so the timely and effective delivery
of the local plan transport assessment
is really intrinsically connected to the
local plan timetable so there is an
imperative to commission an assessment
such as this
um as as soon as soon as possible really
uh to make sure that we are in a
position to make informed decisions at
the appropriate time
so I won't read the detail of the
potential methodology now but in within
the report there is quite a lot of
detail about the approach that may be
taken
one thing I would say is that what we
are suggesting uh that we do is to use
the South Essex model which is operated
by Jacobs and the reason that we're
suggesting that we do that is that it
will provide quite significant cost
savings relative to going out to procure
a whole new model mainly because clearly
Jacobs via Essex County Council have
already collected that data over a long
period of time and won't be recharging
us for use of that data
um the other Advantage is that it
reduces the risk of duplication because
Jacob's relationship with the County
Council does mean that there is less
need for things to be re-run and
reconsidered which inevitably would
cause time and cost uh implications but
that's not to say that ultimately
there's any level of deferral over
decision making or the content
ultimately like with any evidence-based
document it is the council's document so
we will be essentially the the
commissioning Authority and obviously
we'll be expecting delivery of the brief
against an agreed specification to the
required standard and so in that sense
we can be assured that it will be a
robust assessment and will be reported
on back to the executive and obviously
at the appropriate time to the planning
policy committee
thank you thank you Mr Goodman
um right two hands um Council ball do
you want to come back first
one of the most important factors is
actually the scoping of of what we do
um we do have a vision going forward for
the district and and that vision is
ambitious but we need to understand how
much that ambition will cost us and
that's the whole idea of the scoping to
understand
if we can do things or we can't do
things obviously there's no such thing
as can't the problem is the finance
behind it and that's the problem so we
need to understand you know is there a
new road that could be needed you know
and what would that cost all these
things are going to come in to the
scoping this is our plan we are the
piper and and they are going to be you
know we're actually paying the piper
to actually play this tune so I think
that's important thank you Council Ward
County
I had to say this but
two points really one we've got duty to
cooperate with our neighbors so we're
not a in a vacuum we're not an island so
how will this
cooperate with those because our roads
don't stop our borders they carry on
through South and Basildon
so has that been taken into it will be
taken into account
and also I really don't know how to say
this but personal experience on
committees I don't really have very much
faith in ringway Jacobs
thank you councilor FD
um I think
I share your word your your view
um I think the point was made about the
data capture though
um and if it's historic data capture you
can't actually go to another
organization to get the capture of
that's how I read it
um but I don't know whether either Mr
hot or Mr Goodman you want to come in
uh well thank you I mean if I can just
address the first point firstly quickly
so in terms of
um duty to cooperate I think what's
important is the South Essex model
contains data from those other authority
areas so in terms of cross boundary
impacts that will be part and parcel of
that there's no compartmentalization of
of the network if you like so in that
sense there will be a lot of
connectivity between that work
um and likewise with Southend which is
obviously unitary there'll be a quite a
lot of effort put in to make sure that
there's some level of synergy in the
inputs at least in terms of the
assumptions and then obviously the
outputs will be what they are and we'll
consider what they say
um I I mean what I would just say about
the the Jacobs aspect I think
um as they are the county council's
consultant and obviously
um the County Council was the statutory
Authority for highways work
um clearly there's a need to going into
a local planning examination really to
have the support of the highway
Authority that your work is sufficiently
robust and that can be supported but
that's not to say that obviously there
isn't a role for members and the council
more generally to make sure that as the
work progresses iteratively that you're
happy with the direction it's going in
and I would hope that that would
mitigate any risks of dissatisfaction at
the end result
um but I think the reasons that we're
suggesting this Avenue are set out in
the report and they are quite from my
perspective fairly profound in terms of
cost and duplication
yes certainly yeah I take on everything
you say and I understand the cost
implications of duplicating work and all
the rest of it now you mentioned members
will be kept up to date and the way it's
going now I'm more at peace with that so
it should be kept up to date
and what would that what would that mean
thank you so I mean traditionally what
we probably would would have done is
taken things iteratively to the planning
policy committee however I think the
recommendation in this report does also
talk about reporting to the executive so
I think probably what we would do
um and probably as uh as we reach or
approach Milestones is we'll probably
bring reports to the executive that
contained information to be discussed
um I wouldn't want to necessarily give a
regularity of that time frame because it
might be the nature of the work means
that a lot gets done in one quarter and
then it's a lot of background work in
the next
thank you it makes me feel more
comfortable
thank you chairman I mean having read
the report and listen to to officers and
and then the answers they give them to
councilor FD and Council walls come in I
mean it seems to be that nowhere for us
to go we have to go down this road of
getting this
report done that we need it for our
local plan and and this is the the best
and most logical way of of obtaining the
information we need to carry on to our
local plan make sure we get that through
thank you chairman Mr Holtman
thank you I agree with your comments but
just just to go back and clarify the um
if there's any confusion between the the
role of the executive and the preparing
policy group so I think um the the um
progress on that would report back into
the planning policy initially and then
come on to the executive afterwards
um you know there's a different role
there's something quite clear from an
executive point for you you're really
sort of um
um understanding the the the delivery of
the contracts is what we brought to here
for this evening but the merits of the
actual um if you like quality of the and
impact they have Upon Our policies and
local plan is for the policy group to
decide but they can report into the
executive afterwards they're trying to
be quite clear that that structure
because there may be some confusion
around there thank you
thank you for that
um all I would add in terms of the
concern about ringway Jacobs is that
there is not a presumption on an
assumption that because they are the
county highways experts they always have
the answer you know they ought to be a
checking balances approach
um so that we don't just dismiss things
well they're the experts so they must
they must be right I think that's the
um point that we're making if I read the
message correctly that we just don't
dismiss it and say well they know what
they're doing we've got to sort of just
interrogate some of the data but as I
think was also said that becomes some of
the more detail that goes through the
playing policy committee this is a high
level strategic document do I sum that
up
pretty pretty fairly yeah negative
members degree of comfort okay and the
other thing I would like to mention
before moving to the recommendations is
an email which I passed on to councilor
Ward it came from uh Council of Crips
now first of all I have to commend
Council Crips for reading the report and
and asking some questions they're not
actually questions that we can
necessarily answer tonight because they
are more appropriately addressed through
the um through the planning policy uh
committee
um but I do want to acknowledge that
those questions are there
they were sent to the chief exec and
myself a couple of days ago and I would
wish them to be fed into the
deliberations so that Council of Crips
is given an interim reply and assured
that they will be addressed in in more
detail so the courtesy of a response any
reply that you're able to give would be
helpful but it may be that the planning
policy committee
um addresses them in more detail as part
of their deliberation is that fair yeah
okay good no other points of questions
okay which takes us then to um the
decisions being recommended at one 1.1
that a local planned transport
assessment be commissioned using an
allocation of up to 200 000 pounds from
the dedicated ldf Reserve is that agreed
and at 1.2 that the assistant director
place and environment in liaison with a
portfolio holder for strategic planning
be delegated authority to oversee the
delivery of the local plan transport
assessment and report on its progress to
the executive members is that agreed
agreed with that um that concludes the
agenda for tonight uh I'd like to thank
all members for your attendance tonight
thank you too for all officers present
uh and uh being here and thank you all
and with that wish you a very good night